San Francisco facing sharp criticism for
a sweeping reparations plan including
from a former BLM activist The Proposal
would give every eligible black resident
five million dollars wipe out all
personal debt guarantee a nearly
six-figure income for the next 250 years
and offer homes for just one dollar
what's not in the plan is a way to pay
for it and San Fran officials say it is
not their job to figure that out but
they seem to be on board with this whole
plan anyway
you have my 100 percent support and
commitment
to implementing
quite frankly all 111 of these
recommendations they are all warranted
but the plan is running into some
opposition of former black lives matter
activist is calling it out
it is so unrealistic to think that the
average family in San Francisco is going
to be able to pay six hundred thousand
dollars extra a piece it's disgusting to
me that we are more focused on slavery
which ended in 1865 than we're focused
on the veterans who are on the Streets
of San Francisco homeless and begging
for spare change in 2023 that's where
they need to start sending their money
Harold they're moving right along in San
Francisco with this plan well when I got
this email from from us I must say my
wife and I immediately changed our
residency from New York to San Francisco
to the um this is I think the young man
the first part of what he said I agree
with this is unrealistic and I'm not
sure this is the way you bring the
country together I think that there was
intentionality around discrimination and
a subordination subjugation of
African-Americans from the birth of the
country but the country has progressed
and we move we've not moved we've moved
on and we as we move on we have to
continue to find ways to lower the gaps
in education and Economic Opportunity
and other opportunity this is this is
the kind of thing when you talk about an
answer like this that just antagonizes
people and I think you divide us even
more I think they're real people who may
feel that this is a serious issue
serious people believe this is a serious
issue who may not share my political
views but might be willing to have a
serious conversation about how we
address some of the inequalities and
inequities but this is not the way to do
it but in case it is I did change
this is near to your home City where you
grew up and it's a place that you used
to love yeah this is uh Harold is right
uh no one should be taking this
seriously at all this is hilarious it's
probably one of the funniest things I've
ever heard so why is it so ludicrous why
why did they do they did that on purpose
they don't want this what they want is
to divide people to create another
commotion over race if you had an actual
practical plan over this it would be it
would be modest it would probably
include it probably wouldn't even
include payouts at all it would be about
education that's what it would be about
okay uh part of this reparations and
we've got to trace it back to who had
slaves who didn't have slaves blah blah
this is going to take forever but if we
can figure this out you don't you don't
pay for Education you get the best
education there is that is called that's
a reparation this is designed by people
who don't who are hiding their classes
and behind their racism I mean they're
hiding their classes and by a race war
so if we weren't sitting here talking
about this we'd be looking at Pelosi
we'd be looking at news and we'd be
looking at the crazy lady on the on the
board that these are all it's amazing
white leftists to do worse things to
blacks to the Aryan Nations ever could I
mean it is absolutely incredible how
horrible these people the big losers in
this just just by bringing this up are
real estate agents how do you make money
selling homes for a dollar and the big
winner is U-Haul because even if this
doesn't happen it plants a seed in
everybody's head that Frisco is a
demented City that's getting more and
more demented get the hell out of how
get the hell out of there even though
this is never going to happen right and
I guess judge please feel free to
comment on anything you want but if you
could say if if this was challenged
legally
would it be a successful challenge well
I don't I don't know if there would be a
successful challenge but you know I
might imagine they they would say maybe
it's a denial of equal protection that
there were whites you know who maybe the
Irish when they came over didn't have it
so great or maybe the Italians were
prosecuted the yellow Sacco and benzetti
you want to go back but here's the thing
that's crazy about it what they say is
we're going to give you ninety seven
thousand dollars a year for 250 years so
if I'm in San Francisco I'm going to
find a black guy and I'm going to marry
him because for sure I get a hundred
thousand dollars a year
I get a hundred thousand dollars a year
and my kids do too but you see I'm
Lebanese Christian we weren't even over
here why should I if I lived in San
Francisco have to pay six hundred
thousand dollars right I mean the whole
thing is bizarre and then these people
are even more nuts is one of the
millionaires who wants this five million
dollars in reparations he's proposing a
red light district to make sure that
those who came in are involved in human
trafficking that they have their own red
light district these people are from
another planet I can't even deal with
them Jesse what about also
we can look at this and say obviously
this is never going to happen Etc but
there probably are a lot of people there
who are living with some false hope that
they're about to get five million
dollars
they gave them false hope the stupid
white liberal with the polka dot dress
is responsible as Greg said for this
catastrophe you're raising their
expectations and then they're
humiliating themselves if you've seen
the actual footage of these hearings
they're singing they're throwing their
arms up in the air they're doing weird
things with weird clothing and they're
making absolutely no sense it's almost
like they took the most uneducated black
people and brought them in front of the
commission and had them just riff that
they want to get paid they're not these
aren't well thought out arguments you
can make a well thought out argument for
a reparation package you've done it with
the Japanese after World War II
internments it's been done with the
Jewish people after the Holocaust now I
think it's a little too late but I'm
open to listening to an intelligent
argument and the polka dot lady is
destroying any hope these people ever
have of getting paid it's based on
emotional trauma which is this new thing
it they say it's generational so if my
great great grandfather was a slave then
they passed the emotional trauma down
generation after generation after
generation and then the road something
but you can take that anywhere I mean
let's say here Lebanese
great-grandfather subjugated my great
great great daughter on one of her
little ships in the Mediterranean I can
I can keep my hand out Janine and I'm
looking at you Janine I know what you
did to my great great granddaughter and
see there's trauma does the size of the
dot on the polka dot dress matter the
bigger the dot the Dumber the girl great
no it's definitely a measure what do you
uh what do you think the sf4 did by by
uh by creating this proposal Jesse what
would you describe that as it's like
shooting a zebra
and you can never go back yeah zebra
can't change his stripes that's true
[Laughter]
I wonder Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now